yeah he's been off the market for a
while
hi Rick wheeler take Beth Dutton to
build my life away
rip is officially off the market ladies
and gents
yeah he's been off the market for a
while he has yeah has
finally got married
shotgun wedding I mean
wedded bliss
Bliss Beth
ah it's never really blessed you know
but it it's an interesting season in the
sense of Taylor wrote you know some
really wonderful stuff and heartfelt
stuff and get to see
you know more of kind of into their
their past as young you know adults and
teenagers um and they did a great job
the actors and actors that were
phenomenal I don't know where to go
you got four choices pick a Direction
they now have a teenager in the mix at
home oh Lord what are they going to be
dealing with this season yeah I mean you
know it's interesting
the way Taylor wrote it I mean it's been
kind of a slow crawl you know and you
know he he certainly hasn't given like
Carter any breaks and four it was tough
love this year there's a little bit more
of like me kind of opening up but he's
also doing great things you know what I
mean he's learning and he's failing
while he learns but at least he's trying
there was a moment in season four that I
like my eyes were watering up good
morning Mama hey baby
you can't call me that
it broke my heart for Him and for her
knowing the characters challenges with
ever becoming a mother yeah so might we
see her soften up a bit if ever possible
with Beth to allow that into her heart
yeah I mean Taylor is good at you know
little little little little little yeah
you know yeah that's slow crawl yeah
yeah and I love that about him he
doesn't ever fully open the gates you
know he lets a little at a time you know
and and let it grow I mean he's he's
really smart about how he how he kind of
controls the characters and and makes
them grow but at a pace that he you know
he loves and respects well it's just
like me you gotta let it marinate yeah
you know tastes even better so that's
like these characters they're just
marinating for it yeah I like to try to
speak in ranch terms
Carter is not so little anymore that
boy's look at me in the eye I don't know
what he ate in Australia dude that's
exactly what I'm saying what this guy
eat between season four and season five
he even said on Instagram I mean he went
from like a little pudgy kid to all of a
sudden lean and tall I think he's six
one and he came in this year and he
looked at me he's like you ain't going
with me this you're cool I said let me
tell you something I'll punch you in
your throat
Kevin Costner and the whole Yellowstone
gang are back and ready to go to war in
season five which is sure to serve up
plenty of drama
you're all fired
Beth here Lino Chief of Staff back to
work
they will fight you they will fight you
dirty is there any other way
now John Dutton Mr Kevin Costner he is
the governor so how is this going to
further complicate things for you and I
would imagine particularly between you
and Beth you know it doesn't really
complicate things as far as like a
personal relationship it's more business
he gives me a little bit more
responsibility this year and Taylor
wrote it again this way where you know
rip has not only just the bunk house but
now he's really the former of the ranch
and he's run the cows and branding them
and just all these different things that
you know in years past John was a part
of so it's it's interesting to see the
growth again of the character of rep and
the more responsibility that's put on
them this is where she gets a Revenge
I'm wondering though is Beth really ever
happy
yeah
you've seen it on screen I love your
suggestion of you know shying away from
the dining room table at the Dutton
Ranch and going to
a smaller table where it didn't seem as
fussy and fake and yeah those are little
things rip does that we love what kind
of childhood
are you working out at dinner time
I'm trying to get her look it's it's an
odd thing to be in the Dutton house I
mean you know it's like letting the dog
into the house for the first time this
year is a little uncomfortable I think
for a rip at first but you know John
obviously gives him some diamonds along
the way I had some wonderful scenes with
Kevin it was really fun this year
signing this order is a declaration of
war
we're already at War
does Taylor give you guys how much
Insight
beforehand Lisa you know this is what
I'm envisioning for the character where
it's going to venture to or does he just
give you a little crumb at a time
you know in the past you know we've
spent a lot of time talking about red
yeah you know and he's you know it's one
of his favorite characters obviously I
think in the beginning he really had a
real affinity for him yeah and and so
did I obviously because I took the role
so you know but we would go back and
forth and spit all these ideas about you
know not only our the way we grew up we
grew up very similar in a sense so and
putting that into the character and and
he just you know he's continuously
allowed the character to not just grow
but really take some pretty big leaps at
times
emotionally and yeah yeah so you've been
a part of the development of this
character yeah I mean this year he's got
a lot on his plate as you know he did 83
he's doing 1923 he's got Tulsa he's got
I mean the list goes on and on he's got
a mayor King stencil you know he's got
all these things so this year was a
little different I mean he's played his
foe but
um also you know he called me early on
and he said something real cool he goes
you know what man
I feel really comfortable with whatever
you want to try this year you know the
character as well as I do have fun and I
was like wow that's a great compliment
because I don't think he does that very
often bands can also expect to see new
faces when the show returns Sunday on
the Paramount Network including 1883's
Don Oliveira and country star Laney
Wilson she has a love affair too
she better not be ruffling any feathers
not John did we'll see I mean but he
does all I'm going to tell you she's
doing some smooching on screen it's one
of the Cowboys with one of them take a
wild guess who could it be it's not
Jimmy well no because Jimmy's yeah he's
a fiance up he ain't denim Richards who
is it
you gotta watch
dogs
no it's wonderful having her on the show
though I'm I'm a big fan of hers and
she's a sweetheart I do this for my
father I don't do this for me
you feel like is the detriment of this
family I mean as as much as like loyalty
is their strength I feel like loyalty is
also can be their weakness in a sense
how do you feel you know there's a lot
of colors within the Dutton family it's
it's hard I don't know if you've spoken
to Luke or you know even
Kelsey and and west but you know the one
thing that when I look at you know them
from an outsider's perspective which is
kind of rip in a way yeah is that you
know there there are a lot of you know
issues within internally and all you can
do as a character especially for rip
again is is to be as strong as you can
and be loyal and and be honorable and be
a friend and that's what rib does
through and through you can always get
on him when you need a body to bury you
know it
foreign